two weddings just about the placement of
the kings as well white king is just an
eternal defensive piece it can never
join the action again those two black
pawns on the left side they completely
lock down the white king black is
playing with an extra king and look at
this he's just going after white's pawn
and it's all about that black f pawn as
you said he's kept it in reserve he's
never touched it so far mama jarov that
black f-born but he's going to start
pushing it down the board soon and here
we go it's rolling yeah and it's going
to cost white as night how is white
ever going to find a way out of this uh
dilemma
it's not what's just going to push this
game over total total
lost you know here for magnus
pushes again though
and uh there we go have we seen a result
i think magnus has just resigned and uh
there we go yeah big result for the
tournament standings massive result what
a result that shaq black pieces yeah
with the white pieces magnus crawls and
loses
this game to shakira mom and dad that
means he is down by one point in the